that's why he's a figure to me it's not
Sam's fault
if some of them you can't say I made 20
million dollars and I'll show you how to
start your own wildly successful
consulting business regardless of the
skills you have you could be a bum on
the street and pay me two thousand
dollars and I'll make you into a
millionaire why I'll show you how to get
clients I'll show you how to make a
wildly profitable business you cannot
say that welcome to fake a guru or real
guru possibly we have a bit of a
challenge to the last video I got an
email from Constantine who wanted to
answer and talk about Sam Evans he said
he's at a much different experience with
the course and he wants to get on here
defend the Guru yeah kind of you know so
anyway introduce yourself hey my name is
Constantine I'm from Romania and I am a
consultant with some of us awesome
awesome awesome thanks thanks for coming
on the show I appreciate you coming this
is our first sort of I don't know it
probably positive testimonial yeah all
right all right so what do you think of
the the video which video the video I
just uploaded at the - vide did you see
my other video about Sam Evans by the
way yes I actually I've seen the first
video I emailed you and a few minutes
later I emailed you again for the second
video because I know the guy I mean he
is my friend we were talking we were
buddies
last year we were in the same situation
oh the person the person who gave the
court review yeah yeah yeah yeah I mean
we know each other and before this call
I was chatting with him on Facebook some
really interesting things ok so last
year me and Alex from the the guy from
the last video we
in the same situation we were struggling
with the course he had a bigger pain
because he paid for the course I didn't
I took it from a friend and yeah we were
just nothing was working like nothing
was working okay
the course was too hard the information
too much too much information like we
couldn't put together a business plan
work nothing or we could but without
results and then I've been in this
situation about five months so five
months without any income and a really
difficult time in my family I start
talking with Alex because he had a
different mindset than me and we were
living in different countries I mean
Romania he's in Italy and things I mean
we I went on with my life and I was like
in one day I just decided that I'm gonna
do something I have to do something five
months without income it's terrible and
then all I did was I opened the Sam's
course again and I started to apply the
first things in the video which is
saying find your passion do what you
like and do what you already know and
don't try to like do a different things
like I was doing with Alexandra we were
doing the same thing completely
differently you couldn't make money from
that all if you are scamming people
maybe
and then I started to do outreach here
in Romania face to face with people
using Sam's informations all the time
like the cells create the new shopper
result hypothesis that he is talking
about and it worked like I signed up
three clients like right away almost you
know like a week I got the money in the
in the company which was really great
and I am charging four thousand seven
hundred our currency so it's kind of a
lot it's it's a high price and people
were able to pay me I mean not people I
went to big companies a million plus
euro in turnover and yeah I was doing
marketing for them specifically
advertising and then just watch them
what they are doing like what the the
process the marketing process and
everything it's it's going in there and
then I started to put meat on the bones
on my offer on my marketing offer so I
made my offer according with Sam okay so
Sam was giving me toes the tightest he
everything's in the course okay let me
have asked you what your what your
what's your education background just so
I know so I did high school in high
school I did economics and then here I
have a degree in business administration
and master's degree in advertising and
branding and I've I had scholarship in
the United States and one in Turkey yeah
so I'm pre all my life since 14 years
old I've been with business stuff I was
reading all the books like every book
starting through the the basic of
economics of accounting from Adam Smith
to all the [ __ ] on the internet you
know yeah including damn log I mean I
know you've thrown like dialogue at many
other guys I was reading the blogs the
books everything and then I went to
university and start to read the books
which are great but here's the thing
with the books and and those little
course udemy you know Sam is like giving
all like the books are here you know in
the marketing from Philly because
marketing is very high you can't really
apply those things but the principles
are are very like academic and then you
have udemy courses who are like specific
how to click there in this you know and
Sam is giving like all all levels so
you're saying his value offered to you
is is that he provides it all in one
package is that what I'm getting right
so all the books in the world about
business package in one and he took all
the trash out or specifically for
consulting okay not for manufacturing or
other businesses okay he is going with
consulting and how to be successful and
for example in the last video the guy
said that and you said that a cold
calling is not working or Sam said this
yeah no Sam is not saying hopefully is
not working she said that it's a slower
process I mean your business is growing
slower if you go that path because it's
a numbers game or whatever there are
more efficient ways to find clients
which is true and then it is it though
is that necessarily true
yes I mean you don't conquer that that's
that's very true you qualify the
prospect this is what sam says you have
to have an offer that gives a result I
mean it's taking a company or a person
from A to B that's it if you solve this
problem I mean it's very easy it's very
simple and this is what Sam's different
from everybody else is giving easy
answers like easy easy for example if I
wasn't going to go to help any education
seven years old no education at all and
start the course I was going to be more
successful than I am now
you know because I gotta say something
here all right all right so let me ask
you this let me ask you do you think Sam
ovens is like more I I think he's in a
very similar field to someone like Dan
Locke Dan Locke does the same thing he
offers
he reads books and he consolidates them
any over sells the price the books and
over promises results the people he's
selling to let me ask you real quick let
me ask you real quick do you think if
you had to say yes or no is Sam Evans a
fake guru no okay what do you define a
fake guru rest because what I define it
as is I define it as somebody who is
making wild promises too that they
cannot fulfill to a vulnerable group of
people and purporting themselves to be
able to teach or get results in ways
they cannot that's my definition of a
fake guru would you agree with that yes
or no okay cuz here's the thing I was
looking like I was I was trying to brush
up right before this call
unlike the things he says in his webinar
so the first thing he says is like I'd
like to invite you to an exclusive
webinar which start off the vet
I I have a little bit of a bone to pick
with people who give away live webinars
or whatever because they're not really
live you know this by the way I know
yeah that's that's fine well I'll tell
you what he said because that's his main
sales funnel and I can play it during
this time try it yeah well give him that
in a second
but here's what he says he says I built
a 20 million dollar business or whatever
he said and then he said I'm gonna show
you how to this is I think something of
a quote roughly a quote I will show you
how to start a wildly successful
consulting business from scratch
regardless of skill no need for a
Harvard MBA anything like that like
basically the implication is bring me
you're poor you're hungry you're
whatever pay me two thousand dollars and
I'm gonna make you a wildly profitable
consulting business that is not true
that's not a promise you can make that's
just not a promise you can make and he's
he's saying oh look at me I made 20
million dollars I'm selling you guys
this $2,000 of course you don't need
skills
you don't need skills yes you do yes you
do to run a consulting business here's
the thing I see you and I see someone
who maybe maybe will find success with
his company or with his with his
business but here's the difference
between you and Sam ovens what I'd argue
is his normal client you have a master's
degree in marketing right you have a
master's license yeah yeah sorry
advertising that's a marketable skill
already not really I mean you have
skills you can land a job or maybe you
can oh I opened the company away before
Sam right away
and I had this idea like what I do now
the principal they know that the
business plan I had it since let's say
2015 before my service was like I'm
gonna do some advertising pathetic
select like pictures and graphics okay
and advertise those and my offer now is
I grow sales from here to here and I'm
able to do that I mean now I'm I'm doing
for retail and e-commerce for service
based business everything that's b2c
business to consumer and the results are
like really really good just because I'm
not focused on making good websites
beautiful and nice videos artistic I'm
focused on providing value to my to
client of my client you know show the
value that's it and then do my I'm doing
my advertising skills and that's just
working really really well you know but
sure yeah is not teaching those skills
anyway so Sammy's not saying to you what
to do
Sammy saying you should do what you
already know what I did before with boys
but but okay here's the whole thing
though here's the whole thing if Sam
haven't said hey come to me with the
skill and I will teach you if you pay me
two thousand or nah I believe you paid
for the upcharge course I think you said
you paid $9,000 pay me nine thousand
dollars two thousand out let's say ten
thousand dollars with all the taxes yeah
$10,000 $10,000 a lot of money Britain
if you already have this marketable
skill or some skill that has the
potential to be marketed and you're
struggling in your consulting business
come to me pay me $10,000 that'd be one
thing but that's not what he says he
says come to me with no skills at all
he's running this ad this ad is life
yeah I believe it is it's it's his
webinar
it's his webinar I mean you can pull it
up right now here I'll show it to you
I'm going to share my screen with you
okay and now let's try it to you here
this is just on his site okay here just
look at your screen real quick yes I'm
ready there should be subtitles on there
but most importantly I'm going to show
you how you can start your very own a
wildly profitable consulting business
from scratch and then actually get
clients be able to provide value to them
and get paid in return and I'm gonna
show you how to do all of this
regardless of the experience that you
have the skills that you have or any of
your background knowledge or any of that
so it's not like you need to be okay
that's why he's a figure to me because
you can't say you can't say I made 20
million dollars and I'll show you how to
start your own wildly successful
consulting business regardless of the
skills you have you could be a bum on
the street and pay me two thousand
dollars and I'll make you into a
millionaire or a while I'll show you how
to get clients I'll show you how to make
a wildly profitable business you cannot
say that oh then you can just say based
on your definition that he is just this
is just false advertising but the
product that he's selling gives the
information to have this transformation
100%
no no because there's a lot of people
who don't experience that transformation
like Alex from the last video didn't
experience that transformation and he
told me that he landed clients and he's
making money from this okay three
clients for clients he's making money
he's in that level I mean what does it
mean same eivin's though in every
achievement of Alex from now on does not
belong to same happens but I'll tell you
another product the sort of issue that I
can't kind of have is that uh the Sam
Evans says you can go look at his
testimonials and how you can look at
one-star testimonials did you know that
he doesn't have a single negative review
on there he doesn't put him on there
first of all he he basically forces you
to leave a review but then he hides all
the negative ones
I did not know that yeah because all the
ones all the one star reviews are
actually positive when you look at him I
tried to look for a negative review I
couldn't find a single one all that all
the one-star reviews I don't know if
he's saying one star in terms of quality
or what is metric for one star is but
there's not a single review on there
that says oh yeah sim oven sucks and
whatever and I had a terrible experience
which surely we have to acknowledge that
there probably going to be some terrible
experiences given any number of
experiences so that's the other thing is
that we're saying oh the product can
achieve all this personal transformation
maybe for a couple people how many of
those people we have no idea and then
also have an idea in OP level we have
1200 members so is suppose that if they
join the up level now there are 15,000
in accelerator and it's evergreen
program I mean they can do it now they
can do it in 10 years where ever you
know button up level there are 1200
people and I can keep you screenshotted
everything you need if you want and wide
about second time if they are not happy
and those people in up level they make
really good money and they give what do
you mean why do they do what the second
time what do you mean by that they
bought the second product from Sam
well you I mean you said yourself you
weren't having good results when you
bought the second product no right
I'm not gonna follow the second product
like I'm not gonna make a course but it
doesn't mean it's not giving the value I
mean I'm a capper I will make a product
based on my service well no your argue
your argument was some of its must be
making people money because 1500 people
have paid for a second course but my
point is is that obviously there are
people who buy the second course without
making any money because you said
yourself yeah maybe
yeah for sure I mean why but why you
would pay six six thousand I mean it
does me because he's a good marketer and
he he falls advertises as we both said
when you false advertise its easy to get
people to buy your product if I if I was
going around saying I could make people
anybody regardless of skill in to make
them all this money I'm gonna get people
who believe me because they're people by
nature are we tend to believe people I
mean it's kind of a human flower not
very skeptical creatures and so we just
kind of believe people in the in the
same time I'm the only Romanian in but
there are other Romanians in accelerator
and I get I got in touch with a few of
them in the accelerator and one of them
for example right now he is running like
a five million euro business that's like
six or seven million dollars business in
Romania for really big corporations here
in Romania and the same he bought he
during the course like three or four
years ago and now he is selling some
corporate consulting something like that
you know and making really good money
and solving the problem obviously for
really big companies one of the
companies for exam is a government
company and yeah Alec and he he is very
successful he got very successful and we
were talking about how Sam he's such an
such an good guru but and he didn't join
the up level because he was
so busy with working okay so okay maybe
there are successful people in
accelerated that they didn't join up
level and maybe there are unsuccessful
people who joined up because they
thought that maybe in up level they can
make money right yeah but I don't know
any so my point like my thoughts about
fake gurus is that it's just it's a
pointless thing to say like well does
this person does this guru have a
successful client or student yes or no
if yes then they're real and if not
they're fake that I think that's
actually a terrible metric the
successful client like the successful
clients it matters but I think what
matters a lot more is their screening
process and how many people fail using
their product because I think it's fine
i think it's fine great if you can make
someone successful take someone to
success sure that's great but what I
have a much harder problem with is all
the people who are out of twenty nine
hundred dollars or two thousand dollars
what I forget what he charges for the
basic accelerator program who almost by
definition usually are desperate they're
wanting to start a new business
especially when you're starting a
business funds are scarce they're trying
to make a better life for themselves and
then what do you in what are you getting
in return you know what I mean like what
what ends up happening is you end up
losing that money because he's saying
that the promise is this is the course
that can take you from nothing to
something from zero to hero and it's
just not it's just not for most people
it's not that so well you know but it's
not cents fold if some of them will say
it is because he doesn't quite he
doesn't quality no he doesn't qualify
his statements appropriately if I say if
I say hey anybody can join this course
and become a successful concert pianist
guard 'less prior back or under skill
and then people join and a couple people
are successful because they have a prior
background in something related to music
so they succeed and then the people who
actually joined based on my promise that
I'll make them into a successful concert
pianist fail because they don't have the
background to succeed and you can't just
bootstrap your way from zero to hero
that's my fault as they say as an
advertiser I have to say hey maybe this
is the right course for you if you're
already super good at this if you
already have a marketable skill if you
already have some kind of niche product
that everybody already wants I'll teach
you how to consult plus you know
whatever consulting plus but how are you
going to tell me that it doesn't matter
whether people have skill whether people
have a background I mean everything with
fake gurus comes down to how you message
your thing when you're gonna sell a two
thousand dollar product to somebody it's
unacceptable for that that the
advertising to be false like in my mind
it's absolutely unacceptable to be false
advertising especially when your
demographics vulnerable yeah I think
some of the things are true what you
said but you know in the same time like
if you buy a book you know okay ten
dollars but you you will never apply
anything you will never open it is the
author authors fault that you didn't get
the result if the author says I this
book and I will take you from zero to
hero with no background knowledge
nothing I'll tell I will open the world
for you then yes I'd say some
culpability lies on the author and then
I would also say it determines on them
it depends on the magnitude of the loss
of for the book I mean it is not a
trivial difference of ten dollars verse
two thousand dollars ten dollars is a
cup is a cup
two cups of coffee for a lot of people
they can take that loss $2,000 $3,000
that's two months of rent for a lot of
people yeah but what do you think about
the 4-hour workweek that's a claim in
the title I have a few issues I'm not
I'm not without my issues with the
4-hour workweek generally think about
SpaceX for example taking people to Mars
here I'll say I'll say this I'll say
this I think I think number one the
4-hour workweek is a is a I would enjoy
I like it you know like a sore butt but
here's the thing but here's the thing it
like I said it's $10 it's $10 it's not
yeah if Sam haven't saw this course for
$10 we wouldn't be having this
conversation right now
no in the same time you know what Sam is
giving for the money that I pay at
$10,000 $10,000 I'm very happy and you
know why I will give you a screen shot I
just did 30% of the course the above and
probably to get me it will take one year
more for 30 more percent because I'm
working and when I need something you
know
I'm searching the curse on finding a
solution and applying that's it
I'm very happy with this and Sam is
giving the value for that man Mahalo
present to to you to somebody with a
master's degree in advertising who's
been reading business bison since you
were 7 years old 14
yeah a 40 tie anyway it doesn't matter I
don't I don't think about myself of
knowing a lot of things about I mean I'm
always learning okay and I when I'm
going to Sam's course and first of all
we are talking about those books about
those informations but we are missing
the most
the most important thing the most
important piece that Sam is giving and
the one that will make me successful and
he will be more successful the mindset
the mindset it's the thing that
transformed me because I I knew maybe
maybe you're right I knew everything
okay I knew let's say I knew everything
from all the books I had all the
information but he is saying like get
rid of those things you know just keep
the ones that they can help you bring
the results get this resource to your
clients and your client should be happy
all the time okay
your clients should be happy and I'm
saying this to my clients do you know I
I have to make my clients happy so they
can make their clients happy so it's I
don't know is real man
I mean what to say the mindset thing I
mean I couldn't do it I know I actually
actually do i I I don't want to talk
past each other here I don't I'm not
disagreeing that Sam Evans helped you
out I'm not disagreeing with that at all
I can I I can see that he's probably
helped you out a great deal and that
just has zero bearing on whether he's a
fake guru look if Sam Evans had a thing
where it said do you have a business yes
does your business how long's your
business been around over a year does
your business have cashflow anything
like that and you don't have to be super
successful but you just have to have
some level of like I have a skill I have
a prod I have something you're not just
some like like people really I mean like
19-year olds they want to start there
because that's what they're being told
is I can make you a wildly successful
profitable consultant and they're also
told they're they a lot of these people
they don't even have a college education
and they're just looking for a way out
of their McDonald's job they're what
fast-food job and they say okay well I
look up my eager ooh here's this guy who
seems to know what he's talking about
who says he's making twenty million
dollars and he tells me join up just
paid $2,000 okay I'll just Bank my last
two months of rent on it because you
know he can transform me it's like if
this person has nothing if he has no
marketable skills it's like nobody can
take you that far so I mean that that
huh that's a lot of my frustration with
gurus and I eventually want to have
someone on who because I know they're
advertisers who work for these gurus and
when I want I want to have an advertiser
on to learn what in the Google AdWords
their demographics are because who are
they targeting advertising is targeted
who is the who is the fake guru
advertising to is it the business owner
maybe is it the hundreds of thousands of
kids looking for a new job looking for a
way out that's another thing there's
another thing entirely okay that's
that's interesting but let me let me say
from my point of view with my clients
obviously because I am qualifying them
they're educated you're doing actually
the right thing your qualifying client
yes but in the same time when I put an
ad on the Internet I get let's say last
week I got 20 calls from twenty calls I
got two prospects let suddenly just
[ __ ] me right people who who will
never build a business they have like
they make $1 a month or something like
that you know sure and they were saying
to them like hey they were one of the
lady she had she was making some
cosmetics homemade cosmetics and selling
online and she told like - in one year
and my advice for her was take those
things go to the metro station and try
to sell in there because he's cheaper
you don't pay advertise you don't pay
you consult on software's and stuff like
that
and she was like no I will never do that
I have a PhD you know this is a mindset
problem and in the same time I'm
thinking like what the heck what if I
make my own program to help those
[ __ ] out you know because they will
never be successful and maybe we will
pick up some yeah this is the
accelerator the Sam is say talking about
I mean take somebody who doesn't know
anything
get them get him to a point and from
there up level or something else
whatever and more but yeah that is the
thing I mean in my mind is the same
thing like I I need something to educate
those people because they came in my
they are coming to my core and they are
wasting my time and their time and I am
just saying to them your name gonna make
money from this and this business is
[ __ ] sometimes they don't even have
a business they just sell without LLC or
something like that you know or they
don't provide any value like they they
buy something from here and sell their
flipping you know I don't agree with
that my approach is to give value in the
marketplace like provide the service or
product solves the problem and that
that's what I read in a lot of books and
this is what Sam said and this is 100%
true I mean it's working that's that's
the roof that's the business actually I
think we both said our points I think
people can try to piece out the truth
and I appreciate having someone on
though who had a positive what a
positive experience with Sam I don't
think that addressed the core of my fake
guru argument but I think it's
interesting to have someone on who has
had some good successes with Sam's
course who finds the value and I think
it'll provide a well-rounded picture to
all of this so thank you for coming on
Thanks and I want to say something for
the end - so you are saying about Sam
Olens but actually
that's a company you know that's
consulting calm and there are people and
right now what I saw is that other
people start to do consulting like Sam
is just the CEO and other people are
doing like everything is like corporate
now you know in the backend I really
don't know how you are seeing guys all
the guys that you are seeing from
YouTube
you see his webinar and YouTube channel
but you don't see behind like behind
there are a lot of people working a lot
of coaches a lot of information some of
the materials are not made by Sam
anymore and I think will be a great
company to watch I mean if you already
have a business go for it if you don't
you will fail anyway
[Music]
[Music]
fail soccer
[Music]